we're going to do anxiety screenings for
adults without symptoms and it's the
kind of thing that I think if you're not
really clued in and paying attention you
might hear that and you might say well
it sounds like a good idea sure extreme
anxiety is a bad thing and why not have
a doctor screen for it this is actually
a terrible idea this is an awful idea
because I'll tell you what this
functions as and I tell you what the
purpose of it is it is to funnel more
and more people into the pharmaceutical
pipeline get more and more people on
drugs they want to like we don't have
enough people on psychotropic drugs
already we don't have enough people on
anti-anxiety antidepressants already the
medical basis for antidepressants has
been destroyed now has been revealed to
be a fraud but still you know millions
of people on these drugs not enough
though for the system they want even
more people and so now they're gonna
they're gonna start screening you for
anxiety symptoms